in the previous episode we realized that
a firebase project is actually a GCP
project under the hood and a data stored
in cloud storage can be equally accessed
via firebase powered mobile apps and web
clients as well as from your GCP hosted
applications in this episode we'll
explore two more products cloud
functions and cloud 5 store
stick around cloud functions is really a
google cloud product which also happens
to be visible from firebase cloud
functions is a popular implementation of
the functions as a service paradigm
where an event in a system such as an
HTTP call or a file uploaded to a bucket
triggers the execution of a small piece
of code a function check out the service
overview episode for more details on
cloud functions an important
architectural difference between the
firebase and GCP approach to cloud
functions is that firebase will offer
you to wrap your functions into callable
functions such functions can be invoked
via the firebase SDK with user tokens
and device instance IDs propagated
directly to the function another
important difference is the language is
supported when using firestore nodejs
and typescript are supported while go
Python and Java are also available when
using GCP call functions directly before
we compare web consoles you can also use
command-line interfaces g-cloud or the
firebase CLI both come with their own
set of functionalities and it's
recommended to decide which one works
best for you and stick to it
to deploy functions with firebase you'll
need to install firebase command-line
tools using NPM as deploying from the
firebase console is not possible in GCP
lion you can deploy functions straight
from the console integrating with GTP's
private source repositories or even
typing the function source code in line
firebase command-line tools do however
come with an API for strongly typed
handling of some trigger events and with
the ability to deploy multiple functions
at once just as you would expect a cloud
function created with a firebase project
can also be managed using cloud console
in fact clicking on detailed usage stats
in firebase will take you to that same
function only in cloud console where
you'll get additional features such as
monitoring graphs a tab to test the
function and the ability to set features
such as retry on failure memory
allocation or timeouts
whichever way you use cloth functions in
your firebase or GCP architecture
they're likely to be very effective at
what they do best small tasks in
reaction to all sorts of events cloud
fire store is Google's state-of-the-art
no SQL document database it is
schema-less and offers to store
documents containing attributes in a
hierarchy of collections it is fast it
supports transactions it's highly
available strongly consistent and it
does not require managing any kind of
infrastructure some will say it's a
service database cloud file store comes
in two flavors data store mode which is
mostly suitable for server projects and
native mode for mobile and web apps let
me focus here on the native mode which
is the one that is common to firebase
and GCP users this mode can
automatically scale to millions of
concurrent clients but what makes it
even more special is the fact that it
offers near real-time notifications this
is what enables synchronization of data
across devices with its built-in offline
support you can access and make changes
to your data and those changes will be
synced to the cloud when the client
comes back online data stored in cloud
fire store can be accessed using
firebase SDKs and of course you can use
either console to view and edit data and
indices and to monitor database access
usage with cloud fire store you can
query the database directly from your
mobile or web clients without the need
to setup an intermediary server to
manage access to your data and this is
why the firebase console has an
additional tab for security access rules
if you are a firebase user shipping an
app that accesses fire store then you
really should use firebase
authentication and think carefully about
you security access rules on the GCP
side there are no equivalent security
rules as you typically access via store
using a service account generally
speaking server-side code is considered
trusted as opposed to Klein code from
mobile apps
finally supported files store SDK
languages include Python node.js Java
c-sharp nod Go PHP and Ruby with
firebase mobile SDKs adding web
Android and iOS support these mobile
firebase SDKs include local caching as a
unique feature to help implement the
offline capability that I mentioned
earlier same project and billing
infrastructure common cloud storage
cloud functions and cloud fire store
services the two platforms have a lot in
common
so whether you're a GCP developer
interested in building mobile and web
apps with firebase or a firebase user
trying to grow your usage of GCP
services you should now have a good
sense of what's possible it's time to
get going with firebase or GCB or both
thanks for watching this video please
like subscribe comment share and look
forward to more GCP essentials videos
[Music]